good morning and good afternoon to you
wherever you are
my name is anita ganza
and i'm a senior research fellow at the
noguchi memorial institute for medical
research of the university of ghana and
today i'm going to talk to you about
bioinformatics of infectious diseases
and the relevance to
public health
i'll first of all introduce my institute
to you
and tell you the steps we are taking to
try to incorporate genomics and
bioinformatics into infectious disease
research
and the public health relevance of
bioinformatics
in the work that we do and i'll use
malaria as a case study at some point
so the nabuchi memorial institute for
medical research is a biomedical
research of the university of ghana and
our core mandate is to conduct research
into
diseases of public health importance to
train postgraduate students in
biomedical sciences and support the
public health programs of the ministry
of health and the ghana health service
we do this specifically through
conducting research into communicable
and
non-communicable
diseases we provide training
support to
in biomedical research for undergraduate
and postgraduate students and provide
high-end laboratory diagnostics and
monitoring and surveillance services as
well
so for public health
in order to support the six
pillars of public health that is health
protection surveillance prevention
health assessment health promotion and
emergency preparedness we use um
we support with diagnosis
and then
some plan for surveillance we are
interested in knowing the circulating
pathogens in our populations and what
this means to public health
and then
we also interested in environmental
samples
so that we know what is circulating in
our water bodies our food and what this
means to public health
so for instance if there is an outbreak
what we do is to conduct
um surveillance for cases
and these surveillances could be either
active or passive so we will
actively go into the communities and
fish out people who have symptoms
and then
we test them and then treat them or
possibly
if they have the symptoms they come to
the health post or their clinics
and they are tested and treated
so the
biological specimen that we take
are used for
molecular epidemiology studies to
support the diagnosis
and potentially to look at the
relatedness of their cases
and then the field epidemiology
bits will suggest the transmission
pattern
of the infection
now there are limitations to these
traditional methods the genotyping that
we do in the molecular epidemiology may
only tell you
the clusters of cases that are present
without much information on the order or
the direction of the transmission and
the size and grouping of the clusters
um will depend on the resolution of the
genotyping method and
to a large extent what we are using is
just
pcr amplification and restriction
fragment length polymorphism which is
very low resolution so we rely heavily
on epidemiological investigation
to
sort of link the cases in order to
understand the transmission patterns
and this
for the most part is very little
information that we have we don't have
sufficient epi information
to track the transmission
and the diagnosis becomes very time
consuming it's subjective
um
it gives variable performances or
results and so we end up not diagnosing
most of the infections and the
phenotyping obviously will be very slow
and
the surveillance with low resolution
genotyping
is what
relies on
very
high-ended epidemiological data which
we do not
have enough of
so we think that pathogen genomics
can help us solve some of these
limitations with the current way that we
diagnose or
we
phenotype or we do our surveillance so
we think this is the way forward
for us
so comparative genomics analysis by high
resolution or high throughput whole
genome sequencing
offers that high resolution for
epidemiological investigations of
infectious diseases and this approach we
know has revolutionized outbreak
detection
monitoring of transmission dynamics of
infection
infectious agents and antimicrobial
resistance across humans
and animals and the environment
so what are some of the ways that we can
use
pathogen genomics to
study public health and diseases or
outbreaks or
pathogens of public health importance
one is
understanding the dynamics of epidemics
so what you do is to sequence and
assemble the genomes of a pathogen of
interest
from an epidemic
you build your phylogeny to identify the
various plates or subclones
and plot the prevalence of subclones
across space and time to understand why
or how the epidemic is
happening
the second
way is to discover
brand new pathogens so
if there is a brand new pathogen what we
can do is to do meth
genomics on samples from patients with
this unknown disease and then blast the
reits against the database of all
known organisms
look at a set of rates that didn't match
to any known organism and you know that
this is the new pathogen so
your sequencing will focus on this um
and matching
organisms
and
after sequencing you can assemble the
genome of this novel pathogen
build your phylogeny and see how it
relates to other members of its genus
and do comparative genomics to identify
genes or elements that are present or
absent in this new pathogen relative to
the other species and this will give you
an idea of
exactly how this new pathogen looks like
now we are also interested in
understanding the drivers and evolution
of within hosts and population level
evolution of resistance so at the
population level
we
tend to look at
look for signatures of selection it
could be
a recent occurrence so selective sweeps
within the genome of
pathogens
that are linked with
resistance
and at the
within the host we look at
heterogeneity within an individual
with respect to the population
so if there is
um higher heterogeneity in the
individual compared to the population it
may be interesting this
may be associated at either resistance
within the clones that the individual is
carrying
now we can also debit the time of viral
infection or any other infection
with a sequence data from viruses in a
patient
we build a phylogenetic tree
where
branch lengths correspond to the
calendar time
and identify the time to the most common
ancestor and this is the time of the
infection and this is normally a
coalescent model and there are different
collision models that are used to
determine the time since the most common
um
ancestor or the time of the infection
the next thing we can do is therapeutic
monitoring of drug resistance so for
instance if somebody
is taking antiretroviral
um
it's an antiretroviral treatment
if you sequence the viruses in this
patient
multiple times
and scan the sequences
for known mutations that confer
resistance to
the
drag
then you can
change the treatment regimen if you find
that that individual with time
as
harboring
resistant um
viruses to the drugs so moving from
green to a resistant red
and then changing the drug so that
the new um variants are now sensitive to
the current drug
now we can also use pathogen genomics to
understand
um the population structure of pathogens
so here we see a cluster but different
plates within this cluster
of mrsa in the uk
these are the two grey
plates and then
germany represented by berlin in the
white
cluster and then and the dark grey
representing portugal and the second
panel
we are using um
the tree to understand
how
the gene flew
from
[Music]
britain
through
berlin to spread to other parts of
germany
now we can also use pathogen genomics to
understand how to predict
resistance
so first of all you can ask what is
resistance
you can look at mutations
versus
compensatory um
polymorphisms
and then
you can use it to understand the effect
of reverence on resistant phenotyping
you want to see whether a rare variant
is now
increasing in the population is it also
conferring resistance now to
a drag or not
now you may you must also be interested
in what information is in the database
and how this database is being
maintained
and you must make sure that your
sequences if uploaded onto the database
and
your sequences
should be either new or comparative to
what is in a database and then
we are also interested in the quality
scores that we will use to identify
what is resistance
in different modes and levels of gene
expression
so quality scores when we are measuring
um resistance using gene expression
data
now diagnosis we can also sequence
pathogens and look for genes that
signify
diagnosis or
markers for diagnosis
here the sensitivity in the sequencing
directly from clinical samples become
very important we have enough quality to
give us sensitive um
enough diagnostic tools
and for clinical metagenomics
and
we want to identify which is the
pathogen or who is a commensal and which
is a
contaminant
and then again
we need to build capacity in order to
achieve all these
for epidemiology there are certain
questions that you would want to
clarify
how can we infer transmission from
genomics data alone how can we infer
transmission when it's not just a strain
but a transcriptome that is moving in
the population
do we have enough special temporal
coverage of annotated genomes to make um
proper inferences about the population
dynamics of an infection
so
yes you can have genomic data but the
data should be enough to give you
um actual inferences about the
population now let's shift to what we do
with malaria
these are practical things that we are
interested in so for malaria control
the
talk in the malaria community is to
eliminate malaria
by 2030 i think that's where we are now
and the goal to do this is to
come up with discovery efforts
at new vaccines drugs and
to maintain the elimination
targets of
zero
prevalence of malaria parasites in our
populations and to do this you need
tools for accurate diagnosis because if
transmission is reduced considerably you
will need very sensitive tools to
diagnose um malaria
and thus we can only use genomic
approaches
very sensitive um
deep sequencing to
pick very low
infections
and we need effective prevention and
treatment regimen
and we need to stop transmission and
prevent reintroduction of parasites in
areas where we have achieved zero
um prevalence during elimination
now what do we currently have we have
vector control interventions like
indoor residual spraying of homes
and then the use of bad nets
and this is targeted at the mosquito
vectors
and we have preventive therapies for
pregnant women and children
who are living in
seasonal transmission areas and even for
populations with seasonal malaria
transmission in certain parts of africa
and we have diagnostic testing
with the rapid diagnostic
kit
and then microscopy is our gold standard
and we have very good treatment with
artemisinin combination therapies
and then we have a very strong malaria
surveillance
and one vaccine that is at a pilot
implementation stage in three countries
in africa these are ghana
malawi and kenya
but the challenge with malaria control
and elimination is the complexity of the
malaria parasite
so the parasite is so diverse
in its nature because it has to surmount
the mosquito
host
and then when bitten
and releasing to the body has to
surmount
the liver stage even moving from
the peripheral blood to the liver stage
it has to surmount the host's immune
system and then the red blood cell when
the liver stage
um
evades invades the red blood cell
so
it does this with very extensive genetic
diversity
it diversifies at various stages and
this makes the whole process very
complex in controlling or eliminating
the parasite and as a result
we have resistance to the
atomic combination therapy
it has emerged and is spreading in the
greater mekong sub-region around
cambodia myanmar
thailand vietnam
lao and now in africa we have rwanda in
tanzania experiencing artemisinin
resistance on a very small scale so it
is spreading and then there is
insecticide resistant mosquito vectors
also a major problem and for our
diagnostic
kids
um
there are deletions in the genes that
were used to develop this diagnostic
kids and so there are about 10 or 15
percent of people with these deletions
across africa and therefore we are not
diagnosing malaria properly
but
technology is advancing so
we are using um nucleic acid
amplification techniques for genotyping
we are using panels of um
molecular barcodes we started with 24 a
panel of 24 now there are some barcodes
that are about 150
for genotyping microarray technology
whole genome sequencing whole
transcriptome sequencing and the gene
drive and then we have a huge database
of genetic or genomics data
and these resources are very helpful
this is a list of some of the resources
available
for malaria and genomics
now
specifically
we are doing um highly multiplex
targeted sequencing and whole genome
sequencing our objective
is to
develop optimal strategies
that
we can use to
look for markers that will help us
understand importation because when we
are eliminating malaria
we want to see which markets are coming
into the population and these are also
being used to track any the effect of
various interventions so if it is um
a drug
or vector control intervention or a
vaccine we are using the special
temporal monitoring of resistance and
parasite population
to ascertain the efficacy of these
interventions
we are assessing
human variation and parasite variation
so we are interested in understanding
how antigens are presented
hello
hello can you hear me
hello
was i timed out
sorry
welcome back dr
ganza you can continue please
sorry about that
yeah i guess it's network
okay
yeah
so i was talking about how we were using
a highly multiplex targeted sequence and
to answer specific questions of public
health importance we are interested in
modeling and statistical analysis to
help us deal with polyclonal infections
and large-scale temporal and
genetic data sets
we want to preemptively survive the
african malaria parasite for genetic
markers of resistance we don't want a
situation where
we are overwhelmed with highly resistant
parasites so we are constantly
surveilling for
resistant parasites
and so
we're also looking for new tools for
drugs vaccine
insecticides and diagnosis
using insemical designs
that we hope to take through for
laboratory validation if we succeed
we're also interested in genetic map and
by linkage or genome-wide association
studies to select genomic regions and a
strong selection
these specifically candidates for
drug resistance and then we are
interested in causal variants for
and highly virulent malaria or severe
malaria
we are also interested in mapping
studies that can help determine
differential expression patterns across
the plasmodium
life cycle to enable us to identify new
drugs and vaccines
sorry your screen is not shared your
presentation is not shared through
screen
sorry about that
yeah
so these are some of the
few studies we have conducted in ghana
to
determine the prevalence of
previous drugs like chloroquine
resistance in ghana and it is through
these studies that were able to advise
the malaria control program
to change the policy from the use of
chloroquine
to the currently used uh first line
atomism combination therapy these are
molecular epidemiology studies we
conducted at our institute
we are tracking the
we are still tracking these molecular
markers of drug resistance of these
previously used drugs like chloroquine
sulfadoxane perimeter men because we are
expecting
sensitive parasites to emerge after
removal of the drug pressure
and the idea is to advise in the future
on either reuse of some of these drugs
in combination
with other drugs or
for
prevention of
malaria
we are also tracking the
frequency of the deletion in the
rapid diagnostic
kids gene in our population
and we are looking for new genes for
diagnosis
and then
this is an example of a study that is
monitoring the effect of um
a vector control intervention that is
the spraying indoor residual spraying in
northern ghana and its effect on
the resistance of the malaria parasites
after this a period of spraying
and we are
interested in
the genetic diversity of the
vaccine antigen
this
red and blue
circle i'm showing here
is
the vaccine strain the current malaria
vaccine
which is made from the circumsporozoid
protein this is the vaccine strain so it
means that all the other strains that we
find in these two regions in ghana
will not um
work with a vaccine
so you see how important
understanding the
diversity of the malaria parasite is
this means that we either have to
develop a new vaccine or incorporate a
lot of these strains because the cross
immunity that was expected
failed
on the field
we have also tried to
incorporate
next generation targeted next generation
sequence and in our
estimation of
drug resistance in our population
and we recognize that this is a very
expensive
endeavor so we have come up with
innovative tools that will still help us
use um next generation sequencing by
pulling
samples from sites we have succeeded in
pulling
100 samples
from one site
so we carry to our central lab two
samples by the pool of hundred each we
isolate dna prepare our
libraries and then we sequence and apply
all the bioinformatic tools to
determine the
prevalence of these resistant markers
and we obtain
as high as 99 or 98 concordance when
these same samples were sequenced
individually so
for population level studies we think
that we can cut cost and still apply
next generation sequencing to
monitor drug resistance
across ghana
lately we are also working with pine
biotech to
understand the
not just the extent of diversity but
the effect of these variants
in our population on the protein
structure and its function
and this is one gene the
plasmodium files from epical membrane
antigen which is involved in the
invasion of the red blood cell we want
to see how
the diverse strains in the population
is affecting its interaction with
another protein the pf run 2
that helps with the invasion of the
red blood cells
so
in summary
what i'm saying is that
if we conduct our clinical studies or
any field study after diagnosing of an
infectious disease and we have our
epidemiology studies and laboratory
procedures we should we can go ahead and
sequence and use
bioinformatics um
in comparative genomics phylogenetics
analysis
to help with
clinical genotyping as well
ultimately
to
bring about public health action on
infection control and prevention
and
individual treatment
i think i will end here and acknowledge
all our collaborators thank you very
much for your time
yeah thank you very much dr
um anita
uh we have a few questions for you uh
can you hear me
yes i can okay um
the first question is
about um
is about um
okay
yeah so the first question is uh it can
you share how you analyze data
but i guess i i guess you you you
mentioned that
yeah so
basically if you
um
sequence your
pathogen
and you align it to the reference genome
and look for
any variants within your sequence
and then so for us if you're doing drug
resistance
after your alignment you come up with
the regions of interest where your
resistance markers are and then you
estimate the frequency of
your markers of interest
and
this is more statistical
at this stage
but
it is the
bioinformatics the complexity of the
bioinformatics involved in attaining
good quality sequences
and trimming your sequences and
doing the
alignment and
[Music]
coming up with your variants of interest
that
we we there is a gap in doing that but
um
we know we know exactly what to do a few
people in my group are able to analyze
this data yeah and after getting your
frequencies then you apply any
statistics based on the epidemiological
question that you you or the epi data
that you have
you attach it and then
you
um
do your statistical analysis
yeah thank you very much for that answer
uh there is another question
and uh it touches um
it touches
how one can track resistance
i mean
like can we track resistance applying
genomic studies
yeah that was the question yeah your
answer that but uh i guess you want to
still have add few things to that
yes i think we have to track resistance
it is very important if you want to
be in the past when we're using a drug
like chloroquine we are not tracking
resistance
and we were just overwhelmed with highly
resistant malaria and parasites and
people we had a lot more deaths in
um
ghana i can say that
so with these new drugs we want to
um track resistance and
um
control it or if we find it in a
particular
hotspot in ghana we want to track it and
then manage it at that point before it
spreads how can we do that surveillance
is now a tool
for tracking resistance so in ghana we
have now 30 sentinel sites by the ghana
health service or the malaria control
program where we
go there
at the moment unwanted
in this
drug efficacy studies
you conduct a study
take people
who come with malaria and then you take
samples from them we test for these
molecular markers of resistance to these
drugs yes at a listening we are still
discovering what the markets will be but
any marker that has been found we are
testing
and
we also do in vitro
testing
of resistance in their labs and then the
clinical
testing of resistance
and
with the pulling of our samples
we think we can do deep sequencing so
that um
we'll pull some posts from these thirty
sides
and we want to do this monthly
do the deep sequencing so that you will
be able to pick
a resistant parasite as soon as it
emerges so when it emerges in a
particular region then we'll focus on
that region and do a more extensive
study so it is doable it's very
deliverable yeah
okay yeah thank you very much for that
answer so uh like she has said it is
very possible to track
resistance yeah
i used to remember that uh as a
microbiologist uh once before i i moved
i mean i became a molecular biologist we
still we use we use the microbiological
waste to also track ray resistance and
now uh we have molecular approaches to
that yeah so the next question uh we
have here is data is that uh
good to see your expertise on
bioinformatics in genomics
and the question goes like this i says
that uh of course we we took i mean we
we get we get help from software
technology to get really bad information
and to analyze some things you know
things about pathogens but uh the
question is how much
is this
uh
i mean how much specific is this uh is
this technology are they error free um
uh
have you been able to
to detect how i mean the best way to
analyze studies that is i mean that is
in this um
in this in this sphere
yes so thank you very much um
like all our traditional methods
microscopy is very subjective
it depends on the microscope is doing it
microscopy misses a lot of
low
frequency or low prevalence infections
so
with pcr
we are able to account for the errors
from
microscopy
now pcr also has got its own error
rating
with
um high throughput sequencing you get
more depth
it is not error free
but the depth of information you're able
to pick the most um
let's say
um
just the first you um
resistant parasite or whatever
phenotype you're interested in
as it emerges
so
you weigh
that the benefits
whether um
and
you want to see whether the benefits
outweigh the risk or
the the disadvantages of the method so
there are advantages but definitely
these molecular techniques are far more
sensitive than
the
standard microscopy or restriction
fragment length polymorphism analysis
that you were using traditionally
wow wow that's that's uh
that's uh
something and uh i know uh in
i mean after a while we would uh
we would uh get to that level of
perfection um before i go to the
question relating to ethics of research
um i guess i would love to uh to take
this next question it says that how do
we obtain statistical information from
the public on infectious diseases i
believe that this this uh this person is
trying to ask about
the sphere of citizen science and its
application to your research
did you say statistical information
can you repeat that question
yeah so the question is how do you do
you do you
uh obtain statistical statistical
information from the public i mean uh do
you go in collaboration with the people
do you
i mean uh what what public health
uh method do you used to get to get
those your samples and you know
information about resistance and
some of these things
all right so
for every study
whether it is the malaria control
program involved or it is a purely
research study you you enter the
community and you have to um
it's called the community entry you
educate the community about your
projects
and you see whether they will buy into
the project
you have to
make sure that they understand the
project that you're conducting and then
you seek their consent so if it is a
clinical study for children
you need pareto parental consent if the
child is over 12 years you need in
addition to the parental consent you
need the
absence of that child
and
that is a voluntary thing
ethically they are not under any
pressure to be part of the study we tell
them
if you don't take part in the study
doesn't mean you're not going to be
treated so
and there are so many communities that
we've worked with and we have built so
much trust
so
they work with us in collaboration we
make them part of our study design or
um
we go to them and ask them what they
think we should be doing for them as a
community so
they they
are part of our study and therefore
they're able to collect um
the
epidemiological data from them
and that helps with our statistical
analysis
yeah
wow thank you very much uh it's very
very enlightening um i believe that our
researchers in the house are taking
teams from these um
uh
like uh
okay um for those that are just joining
hossa we're on to uh dr anita ganza our
research includes building capacity in
the use of
of uh of p
for c
param that's uh a
a
parasite and uh
and uh she uses genetic data to describe
the extent of the genetic diversity of
the parasite uh uh you know one
discovery of new genes and snipes uh
that has been biologically i mean that
is politically important
to to research and
she also has been able to adapt um
bioinformatica
um advances to to to for their research
the last question i will be asking um
from you uh concerning these as you
close on this note is the question of
ethics uh yeah you mentioned eta but i
would love you to to specify uh because
of your of your studies uh what uh what
major ethical concerns uh
are reason or
or as a likelihood of arising uh
and how do you do you go around to solve
some of this ethical issues that that
relates to your your your research work
yeah so um as i mentioned
um
some of the key concerns that we have
with study participants are that
sometimes there is misinformation people
think that um
you are giving them a drag that may
affect them in different ways there was
a whole haha about the introduction of
the vaccine
the malaria vaccine in ghana and
we had to do a lot of community
engagement
public education for people to
understand
the importance of
the science behind
the
vaccine
and to understand that it was not going
to harm them
and there are issues
about um
[Music]
the risk involved in doing some of these
studies
normally the kind of samples we draw are
very low risk you tell them
um this is slow risk but if anybody is
affected in the course of the study that
person there are arrangements for
care for that person
and um
[Music]
so in terms of
the risk to participants we take care of
them we work with clinicians and so
but to a large extent we work on very
low risk
studies just either a finger break
sample from an individual
does not really hurts them
yeah
and we will make sure that we do not
coerce participants into
taking we respect um
participants confidentiality we try to
go by
the ethical rules for the conduct of
research and
we
make the we give so much information and
our contact so that participants
can call you
with the principal investigators or the
leaders on the project
for any and explanation and they are
free to withdraw from the studies at any
point of
the study
yeah
thank you
uh thank you very much dr anita i i
guess that i will be reaching out to you
more uh in the nearest future
on this note i would i would be sharing
my screen now
thank you very much
thank you
um if you have other questions uh i
would love that you you write them down
or you reach out to the uh to your to
your program director or your
um
your community your community engagement
manager because uh because it is going
to
i mean it's it's something that
that we will
we would love
love to to answer in the long run